cleaning up in kharkiv after a morning
missile attack early today in mikalayev
the aftermath of another Russian missile
strike
while in Kiev and other cities they are
facing new weapons attacks by kamikaze
drones that Ukraine and the West say are
supplied by Iran a new and destabilizing
player in the war on one hand you have
Russia which is uh taking part in a
barbaric illegal and unjust invasion of
another country and on the other hand
you have Iran one that is known for
partaking and destabilizing violent
actions in the region as well the
Kremlin today said it has no information
on the use of Iranian drones and in
Tehran the government denies sending
drones to Russia saying it takes no side
in the Ware
so just three months ago Russia's
president left the country to visit with
the Iranian leader the use of Iranian
drones signals to some a level of
Russian desperation it shows a weakness
in terms of military capacity that
Russia is not able to build these drones
in sufficient quantities in quality
themselves the new Onslaught signals a
turn by Russia to Target civilians and
infrastructure Ukraine says 30 percent
of its power stations have been
destroyed in the last week blackouts are
becoming widespread the two sides are in
an increasingly drawn out fight in the
Eastern regions that are now claimed by
Russia so Russia appears to be mounting
new aerial offensives missile strikes in
mikalayev and denipro and drone strikes
are taking a toll in Kiev and other
cities Vladimir Putin seems to be
shifting from what was a purely military
campaign of aggression to one that
involves a terror Campaign which is
directed largely as civilians at
infrastructure president
Vladimir zielinski is calling again for
more air defenses and NATO says it will
supply them to combat drones
meantime ukrainians are protesting
Iran's involvement in the war but they
are also preparing for what's to come
more Russian attacks and what could be a
cold dark winter Eric Sorensen Global
News